let's move on to our five headlines
[Music]
okay number one chicago mayor lori
lightfoot was uh out this weekend
serving and protecting the the citizens
of chicago
and lightfoot found a dangerous group of
law
breakers who uh she she was sure must be
brought to justice
and well let's just take a look um
here's here's what she tweeted
it's a picture of a bunch of shirtless
guys and speedos
standing around in the grass near a lake
i guess and she says
it's called a pandemic people this
reckless behavior on montrose beach
is what will cause us to shut down the
parks and lakefront
don't make us take steps backwards and
then she follows up in case you were
wondering i stopped by to see for myself
it's being addressed yes
um the shirtless speedo guys at the lake
they're the uh they're the problem here
take care of them
you know because that's that's the real
issue it's them
and not this what you're seeing here is
looting in chicago again last night
they were looting all over the city no
comp in sight in many of these videos
uh because lightfoot has them focused
you know on the speedo problem and not
the looting and rioting problem
um you know not the problem of anarchy
and destruction raining down on the
street again
and again and again and again and again
night after night after night
after night if you're curious by the way
they're doing this
ostensibly because police shot a guy who
had a gun
and had shot at them the guy didn't even
die as far
as i know but there was a guy with a gun
shot at police
police shot back he got hit
and now they're rioting because of it
because police i guess are supposed to
at this point they're supposed to just
drop their guns
and just offer themselves up to be
killed just walk up to the bad guy and
say okay i'm here
do what you will anything less than that
is oppression but you just look at these
and um you see these these
the footage here uh you know this is
this is obviously this is a fascist
dictatorship
where cops murder people in the street
and all of these poor protesters live in
fear because of it
yet every night people casually riot and
loot and stroll aimlessly out of burned
out retail outlets
with armfuls of stolen shoes does that
make a lot of sense to you
does it make a lot of sense for for you
know a woman who who's who's
wandering out of a coach store with a
box of stolen purses
saying i live in fear of the police
i live in fear that the police will come
any time and kill me
is is that what you do with it i mean if
you're being oppressed and you live in a
fascist dictatorship
and you're worried about police who are
prowling the streets just looking for an
excuse to kill somebody
this is how you respond i mean
are these people who who really seem to
be afraid of authority
no it would seem like the problem is
very much the opposite
number two let me just give you the
headline here from the daily wire it
says
hasbro pulls troll doll amid concerns
that toy normalizes sexual exploitation
that's the headline and i have to tell
you my wife
um informed me of this controversy the
other night and and uh
said that there was some kind of thing
about a trolls doll and
my immediate reaction upon hearing that
was to think that's just another example
of people being hypersensitive and
dramatic
not to mention i thought if somebody
actually sees a trolls doll
and and ties it into anything
sexual well that's just a reflection of
their own perverse
mind okay that's like get your mind out
of the gutter
that's what i thought until i saw the
video
of the doll in action and uh it kind of
changed my perspective
a little bit in order to take it out of
demo mode
you have to the instructions say to sit
doll so you put her legs
out and you sit her down
for five seconds which by doing that
um he pushes the button
but now
oh
oh
[Music]
i cannot believe that like this is
insane
yeah that's that's uh
disturbing that is definitely disturbing
now hasbro claims that they place the
button there because
it's it's supposed to make those noises
when it sits down
but first of all why would it make those
noises when it sits down is that does
that make sense
since when does sitting down elicit
sounds like that from from anyone even a
troll
second even if there was uh you know
even if there were
innocuous intentions behind this how
could it be that
nobody at hasbro through the whole
process of manufacturing and
distributing this thing
how could it be that nobody anywhere
ever went
uh guys this is a button in the
doll's crotch area
that causes it to squeal when you touch
it that's
uh that's weird guy like how did nobody
think of that how did nobody point that
out
see here's the thing i'm never perplexed
by
uh individual people doing stupid things
that doesn't
ever surprise me and i'm also not
surprised by whole groups of people
doing stupid things all at once like
we've seen in our streets across the
country
uh and in chicago last night so none of
that like stupidity and mass hysteria
okay neither of those surprise me i get
it that's how people are
but what what always does surprise me a
little bit
is when you've got a succession of
individuals
making a considered choice and that
choice right down the line is
horrendously insanely stupid
that's when i scratch my head because
you don't really have the mass hysteria
element
and it's not just one person so there's
a right there's
checks and balances here and right down
the line i mean literally down the
conveyor belt
nobody noticed anything wrong with that
um now some people are saying this was
done
to intentionally advocate child sex
trafficking or whatever
you know i think that theory is a little
bit intense um
i go back to hanlon's razor which is
never a tribute to malice what could
easily be explained by stupidity and so
i think that probably applies here but
either way it is uh
very weird to say the least number three
i'm going to play this for you with no
setup just
just watch if you look at like the 1990s
and the way that
rush limbaugh and others sort of sharpen
their teeth on bill clinton
this has been the way they've built
audiences for three decades now
yeah i don't want to claim it's new i
just i'm arguing that it's getting worse
it's getting more severe uh erin your
view of this you know
when you see um entire media companies
essentially exist
to tear down joe biden is there an
equivalent to that on the left tearing
down trump
uh there really isn't and you know what
i would say it it's really a diet of
this
type of information that a lot of these
voters are getting a lot of the voters
that i talk to i can uh you know when i
interview them i do hear
uh them saying a lot of the talking
points that sound very familiar from
from some of these shows which i try to
listen to
when i'm out on the campaign trail or
when i'm at home you know watching tv
you know you can you can hear these uh
these comments being echoed
uh by voters and you know that this is
the diet that they're on uh con
you know am radio uh you know
conservative talk
uh also social media i mean the trump
campaign is running a full-blown
campaign on social media
that is completely off the radar for for
a lot of
a lot of uh you know regular media is
not covering this but i mean you have
folks
laura trump kimberly guilfoyle katrina
pearson the campaign
is is running you know kind of a
parallel campaign
online and and if that's all they're
getting you know to the exclusion
of kind of the more traditional legacy
media uh you know then
it really is no surprise kind of of what
their understanding is of this country
and of our politics
such an important point though simply
amazing that they could
keep a straight face throughout that
exchange
is astounding i mean this is really this
is like
a guy dumpster diving naked
chowing down on like a soiled diaper
maggots all around old banana peel on
his head
comes back up and says you know when you
see people in drive-through lines at
sonic
i mean that's really unhealthy that's
that's that's got to be the most
unhealthy diet in the world right
takes another chomp of the diaper just
the self-awareness level here is
arctic levels this is sub-zero okay
self-awareness
number four cnn is trying to whip up a
race controversy and i know
that you hear that statement and it's
rather evergreen okay you hear that and
you think oh so it's monday okay
but let's be more specific uh here
here's the latest fake race controversy
from cnn
reading now from their article says a
black student was forced to take off his
black lives matter face mask in order to
graduate his family says
dean holmes a student at york catholic
high school in york pennsylvania put on
a black lives matter mask under his face
shield at his
july 28th graduation ceremony as
students lined up before the ceremony
started the school's
principal pulled him away in front of
the other students and told him to take
off the mask
holmes had previously been told by uh
by another school official to take the
mask off so he eventually relented for
fear of not being able to walk across
the stage he said
uh holmes said quote i was so mad i was
shaking during the graduation tapping my
leg on edge
when it was over i couldn't believe it
york catholic had opted to give every
student a facial instead of a mask for
the ceremony
holmes's father john took to facebook on
saturday saying that
the school stifled his freedom of
expression and jeopardized his health
the capricious this is the john now the
capricious action taken against my son
demonstrates that york catholic high
school has miles to go before they can
put the ugliness of unconscious bias and
racism to sleep
as a parent i will not stand for my son
being humiliated publicly
having his basic human dignity crushed
on what should have been one of the
happiest days of his young life
okay a few things to cover here first of
all
john holmes calm down you drama queen
basic human dignity crushed because he
couldn't wear his favorite face mask to
graduation
his human dignity is crushed because of
it that's how you crush a person's
dignity really
well if your sweet precious child's
dignity is hinged on
something as superficial and weird as
his face mask
that's a different issue okay he needs
counseling for that
also dean holmes calmed down
you drama queen you were shaking really
you were so sad and upset you were
shaking because of this
because you couldn't wear your favorite
face mask what kind of man
shakes when he's upset much less admits
it publicly
you're the one crushing your own dignity
i agree your dignity has been crushed
but by you not by the principle also
most importantly
just so you know the school has a policy
nobody is allowed to wear anything to
graduation that has
any kind of message on it nobody
that's been the rule at the school since
always and it makes sense
they don't want graduation to turn into
an event to advertise political
viewpoints
or any other viewpoint and they want
uniformity that's
every graduation i've ever been to and
i've been to quite a few that's how it
is
everybody looks exactly the same there
was a there was a there was a
hubbub at i don't think was at this
school but at some school a couple years
ago
when a student i think was at a college
wasn't allowed to wear his uh
his military dress blues across the
stage at graduation
and even there i would say i mean
obviously it's
a wonderful thing that he has the
uniform and that he serves this country
but
at the graduation this is it's a
different uniform and everybody's
supposed to look the same that's the
point
so there's a dress code is the point and
everybody is held to it
no exceptions it's a dress code you have
to just follow the dress code like
everybody else you're not special why
should dean have gotten an exception
because he is is he special why is he
special
because i know he's daddy's special boy
but does that mean
why should anyone else care about that
give me one good reason
why this particular person should be
exempt from the dress code
that everyone has always been expected
to follow
that's what dean's uh father that's what
john
holmes is saying here what he's saying
is yes there's there are rules and
there's a there's a dress code
but my son is special he shouldn't have
to follow the rules
this is my special son oh shut up
this is this is this i mean among other
things this is terrible parenting
you're the father you you should be the
one your son
is crying and shaking because he had to
follow a dress code
as the father you're supposed to be the
one smacking some sense into him
instead of going to facebook
you'll never believe what happened to my
boy
shut up number five
finally the national park service posted
to facebook a couple days ago
um giving advice on what to do
if you come across a bear and they say
if you come upon a stationary bear move
away slowly and sideways and this allows
you to keep an
eye on the bear and avoid tripping
moving sideways is also non-threatening
to bears
do not they say run but if the bear
follows stop and hold your ground
like dogs they will chase fleeing
animals do not climb a tree both
grizzlies and black bears can climb
trees
do not push down a slower friend even if
you think the friendship
has run its course now i know this last
comment about the slow friend was meant
to be a joke right
but i just want to say this uh you know
this is not a joking matter
and they shouldn't be making light of it
um yes you absolute obviously you
absolutely should not push
down your slow friend if you come across
a bear
that would be an awful thing to do um
because if you push him down then he'll
be in a submissive pose and the bear
might not attack him
and may keep pursuing you instead so and
this this is really a point if your
friend is slow
there's no reason to push him down let
his slow
dumbass keep running you go off in the
other direction and the bear is going to
go for him i mean this is just
basic now if there's something you can
do to slow your friend down further
without stopping him from running so
let's say for example
you're in a lake or something and you
come out of the lake and uh there's a
bear
there um so one thing you could do is
grab his shoes
and run off and now that's going to slow
him down hinder him a little bit
and then when he gets mauled and killed
by the bear the bonus is
you also now have a new pair of shoes so
i mean these are things you could do
i just i was really disappointed that
the national park service had an
opportunity for a real teaching moment
here
but instead they went for the joke and
that is as i said
just really really disappointing well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date
on all of our future content